[Music]
foreign
hello good morning and welcome to safety
Ridge on Sunday happy coronation weekend
and what an event it was yesterday and
the party course continues today you
might have noticed though we're still in
Westminster for the show this week
rather than our Sky News coronation
studio and that is because despite the
celebrations and the ceremony there's an
awful lot of Fallout still from those
local elections and if you feel that the
pause and coverage of those
extraordinary results if you're wanting
more analysis you're in the right place
we will still be reflecting on the
coronation of course and in particular
whether the police were heavy-handed in
dealing with protesters
on the show this morning our top guest
given the council results pointing to
labor forming the next government it's a
shadow Health secretary where's
streeting
we'll also be discussing the results
with the culture secretary Lucy Fraser
and plenty to talk about when we sit
down with the lib Dem Deputy leader
Daisy Cooper
plus to talk a bit more about how the
conservatives can improve their chances
at the next election will speak to the
conservative MP for thoric in Essex
Jackie door price
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning now the local elections
marked a milestone moment for labor
they're now the largest party of local
government overtaking the conservatives
for the first time since 2002 and if the
results were replicated in a general
election it would be care starmer in
number 10 even if it wasn't quite enough
for an overall majority well earlier I
spoke to the shadow house secretary West
rating
oh great to have you on the program this
morning so you were at the coronation
yesterday any particular highlights I
mean the whole thing it was an amazing
event and I thought especially against a
backdrop of things not working in our
country across the board great to see so
many things that make our country great
on display whether it was the music the
spectacle the military processions the
fly pass the celebrations of people
coming right together across the the
country it was just an amazing moment to
be there and also really nice talking to
people in The Abbey who had been chosen
to attend because of their voluntary
service their community service their
Public Service which I thought actually
spoke to directly to what Justin will be
the Archbishop of Canterbury was saying
about the theme of the coronation you
know around service to others looking
out for other people so really wonderful
occasion and obviously a massive
privilege to be there are you a bit of a
royalist then I am I I think our
constitutional monarchy has served us
really well
um and I think that you know 300 million
people I think it was watching right
across the world
um is a good thing for our country
actually and you know just reflecting
back on some of the royal visits we've
had in in my Borough over the years
anyone who met
um the late Queen anyone who's met
senior members of the royal family it's
a really special moment actually and a
way to
um I think recognize and celebrate
people in a way that wouldn't quite be
the same if we'd had a different system
you mentioned the lake Queen there who
obviously people felt such affection for
war and you know an honor towards what
kind of King do you think Charles will
be I think you'd be a good King I think
we know that he cares about a range of
causes but of course now he's the king
and puts some of that to one side but I
think do you think he should have had
some of that as on side then well of
course he has to but as a head of state
uh it's it's the responsibility of the
king or the queen to bring people
together and I think there are ways in
which the royal family on issues of
consensus and important and issues of
important National significance or
International significance can bring
people together whether that's on issues
like tackling climate change or actually
the role of the monarchy as part of
Britain's soft power their diplomatic
pulling power there are lots of ways in
which the royal family add enormous
value to our country collectively let
alone those special moments of the
garden parties and the Royal visits and
I want to talk to you a bit about the
policing of what happened because they
have
to have the people protesting the
coronation now the Met released a
statement they said we understand public
concern following arrests made this
morning we police proportionately and in
the context of the event it's a Once in
a generation moment that's been a key
consideration
do you think the police response has
been proportionate well firstly I'm glad
that the police are providing context
and recognize the accountability that
comes with policing I think Mark Rowley
the Metropolitan Community Police
Commissioner knows that there's a lot of
work to do to rebuild trust with the met
in particular so that transparency and
that accountability is important I think
it's also important to recognize that in
Trafalgar Square for example there was a
significant Republican protest that took
place peacefully without incident
um you know as you said I'm someone who
supports the monarchy but I respect
people who have a different View and I
respect their right to protest and I
think the police does too there are of
course some cases that being raised
probably not important I don't comment
on specific cases while there are
potentially still investigations or
action ongoing but that accountability
piece is going to be really important to
make sure that the policing was
proportionate and to make sure that
where people have concerns that they're
addressing I understand you don't want
to talk too much about specifics but I
do want to talk about some of the
specifics I think it is quite important
to give the overall picture you know
because for example three people
reportedly arrested volunteers with the
night Stars program so that's you know
Westminster council's Street safety
program handing up rape alarms and this
kind of thing is quite worrying as you
say there is concern about policing by
consent as it is yeah and and it's that
principle that's important policing by
consent I know Westminster city council
has put out a statement expressing
concern and asking for that to be looked
into I think that's an important thing
to do and if the police have been
disproportionate or got things wrong
it's important as we've seen with the
Casey review that they hold their hands
up and acknowledge it I'd also just
acknowledge that days like yesterday are
really difficult for the police it's an
enormous Security operation there were
concerns I know I got it right then
that's what I'm trying to get I mean the
truth is Sophie um you know I didn't
wasn't there didn't see not across the
details of specific cases yet
and so I don't think it's appropriate
for me to provide a running commentary
without all of the facts I think it's
the accountability that's important and
where concerns have been raised whether
that's
um you know by Republic
um you know the the campaign for um an
elected head of state
um or people more generally just
concerned about what they've read in the
papers or seen on the Telly it's
important that the police provide that
accountability in principle then
anti-monicle protesters are they in your
my eyes is it reasonable for them to go
along peacefully protest but noisily
protest for example yeah
um if if you're a republican of course
you're going to protest around the
coronation if you're not going to do it
around the coronation when would you and
I don't agree with them but I absolutely
respect their rights protests and
actually in terms of things that make me
proud of our country and our democracy I
think it's the fact that you can have
those two events taking place
simultaneously the spectacle in the
Abbey thousands of people packing the
mail the street Parts across the country
and have that space for people to
express a different view to protest
that's one of our strengths as a country
and I think there's one reflection I
just offer as a politician actually
reflecting on the divisions in our
country many of them political divisions
we've got to learn the art of being able
to disagree well in Britain and to hold
different views I strongly hold them
robustly debate them but to do so in a
way that's respectful and and you know I
don't agree with the Republican
protesters out yesterday I absolutely
respect them I think their point of view
is legitimate and I respect their right
to voice their views right let's talk
local election shall we you must be
pretty pleased with the result we are
very pleased we're I mean with the
results that we saw right across England
in every corner of England were
encouraging I mean important end of the
of themselves I should say for those
labor local government leaders who are
now going to be able to do things to
deliver for their communities having one
power in places like Plymouth and Medway
as well as in the north of England as
well uh you know games right across the
the country
I think for the next general election
labor feels confident but not complacent
and I want to make sure that both of
those things are heard because yes I
think those results do point to enormous
progress made under kirstarma's
leadership he's changed the labor party
now he's got a hearing to be able to
change the country but there's more to
do and our labor has said the results
show that you're on calls for a majority
of the next election and I'll be honest
oh you've got that okay so what the
experts are saying is yes it's great but
you wouldn't get a majority and if we
look now I think we can have a look at
the House of Commons projection from
Rollings and Thrasher so these are the
experts I know you're going to say look
you can't read across from local
elections to general elections but
according to this you wouldn't be on
course for a majority would you and this
is because you know you're starting from
such a bad place frankly at the last
election that you need such an enormous
swing to get there and these results
don't put you on course for a majority
well you're you're right Sophie I am
going to say that these are you can't
read across but it is important to say
that this is this is not um a prediction
for the next general election this is
what would have happened if the local
elections have been a general election
and they weren't for a number of reasons
let me let me show you another graphic
and in that case I want to show you
these the council suit graph going back
in time historically and I think we can
bring that one up because I understand
the concerns about the majority
predictions the House of Commons
projection but let's have a look at this
this is Council suits going back through
time and because you're starting from
such a bad place you would need an even
bigger National swing from the
conservatives than in the 1997 landslide
and if you analyze the local elections
you're around nine to ten points ahead
but at this point before the 1997
election Tony Blair was about 14 points
ahead in 1996. so you wouldn't get there
would you it's not showing that you'd on
course for a majority well I'd say two
things one is if you told us in 2019
that this is where labor would be four
years following that worst defeat since
1935 I don't think anyone would have
said that was possible but kierstama has
changed the labor party and earned us a
hearing with the voters who turned their
backs on labor and people are turning to
labor again that's why I say we're not
complacent we know that there is more
work to do to earn people's trust and
support but on the basis of the results
we saw on Thursday we are confident that
labor can win a majority in terms of our
policies for the next general election
in terms of the results that I think we
will get the next general election The
Best Is Yet To Come would you be
prepared to go into a college
we're not even entertaining that
Prospect Sophie because directly not
even I'm not I just don't think that is
the scenario that we're going to be in
after the next general election and if
it is which is very possible looking at
these results
I honestly think Kia starmer could
literally be on the way to the Palace in
the car having just been
um summoned to be prime minister of a
majority party and the conservative
party in some parts of the media's
talking points would still be always a
difficult night for the conservatives
but labor could have done better come on
I I'll give you my word if that is a
scenario that happens I will not be
asking these questions however in these
scenarios where the results Point
towards a hung Parliament is a
legitimate question to answer yeah I
know I think we're this is a this is a
process not an event we're not at the
Final Destination yet in terms of the
general election and just give you a
couple of examples as to why we
shouldn't read the local elections um
right across take hold where I say
through gritted teeth the liberal
Democrats did rather well I heard the
lib Dem leader of whole Council the
other night saying well look locally
people have voted libden but the general
election people in the city vote labor
in Worcester where again mildly through
gritted teeth the greens did rather well
again I heard the green saying well
local elections we fight locally but the
general election this will be a labor
versus conservative fight and I'm
confident that we will win Worcester for
for labor but we're not complacent about
this and there's so much more still to
come kirstan was going to be setting out
labor store in terms of our big mission
to not just cut NHS waiting lists but
build an HS fit for the future later
this month if that'll be followed Again
by a bid education opportunity in terms
of educational opportunities narrowing
the Gap in life chances between kids
from working class backgrounds like mine
and more wealthier backgrounds there's
so much more that labor has in store and
so much ambition and that's how we'll
win the next general election let's talk
about this shall we because if you are
going to be the government waiting are
you going to need some big radical ideas
uh last week kistama told me that the
NHS isn't on its knees it's on its face
so what's the big radical idea for the
NHS are you willing to take on the
vested interests so as well as
delivering the biggest expansion of NHS
staff in history funded by abolishing
the non-dom tax status more doctors more
nurses more NHS staff to bring down how
much is that
just over three billion pounds and the
NH because if you look at the overall
budget that's kind of it's not exactly a
huge injection of money is it well I
just say yeah two things on that firstly
we know that investment matters the last
Labor government showed that but so does
reform again the last Labor government
showed that too we managed to deliver
the lowest waiting lists and the highest
patient satisfaction in history in the
NHS by that combination of investment
and reform so to your big idea challenge
we've got to shift the focus of
healthcare out of the hospital into the
community because if we can fix the
front door to the NHS in primary care
where GPS are currently overwhelmed
there are thousands fewer GPS now than
there were before we've got people
waiting far too long to see a GP because
the GPS we have are desperately
overstretched and burned out if we can
get that front door to the NHS fix it
means faster diagnosis which means more
effective treatment and less expensive
because if you go and see a GP it costs
about 40 quid for an appointment if you
go to accident emergency it costs about
360 pounds so he's not convinced by your
plan and so and the BMA have told me
that you know you're not they're not
sure that you'll really understand the
house service well we're winning people
around I think it's fair to say in terms
of general practice I spent a lot of
time not just during the election
campaign but previously actually our in
general practice talking to GPS and the
wide range of Staff
um who work there I think they they
aren't they get the most important thing
which we recognize that they're they're
stretched there aren't enough of them uh
we need to get the Cavalry in to support
them but I think they also see and I did
a big speech at the king's fund just
weeks ago that if we're serious about
having an HS that fit for the future
that means having Better Community
Health Services faster access to primary
care so that we can do faster diagnosis
more effective and less expensive
treatment which is better for patients
and better for the taxpayers should
private sector involvement in the NHS be
a dirty word
uh no I mean we're going to have to use
the private sector to bring down NHS
waiting lists um the last Labor
government did that very successfully
that was that was part of the picture I
think the anger I feel today is that so
many people are feeling forced to go
private because the NHS is unable to get
to them in time and that's created a
two-tier system where those who can pay
a scene faster and those who can't are
left behind and that's why I've said you
know we would use the private sets to
bring down an HS waiting list because
for me it's not just a pragmatic point
it's a point of principle why should
someone who's working class or you know
short of cash be left behind while
they're next door neighbor is able to be
seen faster but I see that as a as a as
a measure on the path to making the NHS
so good that no one feels forced to go
private because that's what happened on
the last Labor government use of the
private sector fell over the course of
that government because the NHS was so
good people said well why pay the NHS is
there okay well if you are a health
secretary for the general election we'll
have come back and we'll see if the NHS
is people will still be saying oh but
could care storm have done better oh
yeah well let's have a seat let's see
we'll we'll talk about the election
results as they come in as we will do
with the government I'll see you there
now with more scrutiny there's always
scrutiny about past Pleasures about
um people changing their minds and I
just want to play you one quick clip of
I think you'll probably remember know
where I'm going with this one but let's
have a quick listen
there's no easy way to say this
we made a pledge
we didn't stick to it
and for that I am sorry
when you've made a mistake
now labor has ditched its pledge to
scratch tuition fees are you getting the
cameras in for your own Sorry video
I think the the important thing is
learning from the liberal Democrats
experience you don't go into a general
election making promises you can't keep
and we're not prepared to do that and
the truth is the public finances are in
such a mess that there are lots of
things that we would like to do that in
all honesty we don't think we will be
able to afford to do now I think I was
talking to you back in the day when I
was president of the national English
students about some of these issues I
I've never supported the nutrition fee
system the way it is it's actually
become worse more unfair on students and
graduates since I was president of nus
about 15 years ago
and we want a fairer funding system and
that's what label be setting out plans
for you say sorry to those people who
voted for kirstan were in the leadership
election on this pledge that he then
broke well they're labor party members
and I think labor party members totally
understand where we are as a pastor will
you say sorry to people who voted on a
false pledge I don't well no I think
people know that in terms of what
kirstan was stood to be leader of the
labor party on the platform he stood on
making labor electable again getting us
back to Power so we can do things labor
members absolutely support Kia stammer
in that and they will understand better
than anyone else because they're out
there knocking on doors they're a huge
part of achieving those results we saw
on Thursday night they know that more
than anything else it's important that
when people pick up Labor's Manifesto
and they look at our pledges and they
look at how they'll pay for them because
it'll be fully costed and fully funded
they they know that voters need to know
that we can deliver every single one of
those pledges and if Kier is looking at
the state of the economy and the public
finances of Rachel Reeves and concluding
there are things that he would have
liked to do but can't afford to do far
better to make those big judgment calls
now before a general election than end
up apologizing after a general elections
the British people like Nick Clegg was
forced to do look weapons the lib Dems
we're not going to make those mistakes
we will set out plans for a fairer
funding system though because I don't
think anyone in the labor party thinks
the status quo we see for students today
where they feel real hardship in their
pockets or graduates who pay their
student loans off but still see the bill
right Rising um year after year we know
that's not a fair funding system we'll
set out our fully costed fully funded
plans for what we can do on higher
education student finance but the
reassuring Point labor will not have
promises in our Manifesto that we can't
pay for and keep okay thank you thanks
we're shooting there on pretty buoyant
form after those results but across
England it was a different story for the
conservatives who lost 49 councils and
more than a thousand councilors which
exceeded even their worst predictions
well a few moments ago I spoke to the
culture secretary Lucy Fraser
thanks so much for being on the program
so you were there at the coronation
yesterday any particular highlights uh I
was it was just everything was so
fabulous a huge advert for Global
Britain you know a spectacle watched by
millions of people across across the
globe I really loved the procession
because you know you saw everything
there you know religious leaders you
know leaders of their countries in their
traditional dress and then you know you
saw a princess Charlotte with Prince
Louis holding hands I just thought that
was a huge moment of you know
International solidarity yeah that was
lovely that maybe when they were holding
hands I thought as well and you've got a
busy day today as well planned busy day
today so um yes later on I'll be going
with the prime minister to the luncheon
number 10 where I'll be hosting people
you know who've been made massive
contributions to their uh to their local
communities and there'll be some
ukrainians there as well so it's going
to be a really fabulous event and then
really lucky to be invited tonight to
the coronation conference
which will show the best of our British
culture and it's been amazing weekend of
spectacle but frankly it has been a
difficult few years for the royal family
some might be asking if they're still
relevant I think they make a massive
contribution to society you know just
yesterday you know seeing 200
representatives from across the globe
there because of the coronation I think
that shows their their power and their
pull and they do so much you know for
communities uh the good works that they
do you know I work very closely with the
princess trust you know what they're
doing for young people so I do think
they have a significant role in society
not everyone agrees of course there were
a number of arrests yesterday
do you think the Met police went too far
uh you know the police are operationally
independent uh from government but what
they had to do was to police you know an
International Event uh on the world
stage and I think they took that into
account in their policing and what they
have to do is balance the right of
people's uh the right to protest which
is important in a democracy at the same
time as the right of all those other
people to enjoy what was a fabulous day
and and I I don't know the the instances
the particular instances but I think
overall they managed to get that balance
right you say that overall you believe
they managed to get the balance rights
um but there are reports of for example
three volunteers working for Westminster
counties Night Safety team arrested for
handing out rape alarms another person
arrested for possessing a megaphone
because it might scare the horses I mean
for some people they might be saying
that hang on
um yes the people have a right to enjoy
um the coronation and the processions
but also people have a right at the
correlation to also make their views
heard of their Auntie Monica it's really
difficult to take snapshots of
particular cases because we don't know
all the facts around that we don't know
whether events for example were
coordinated so I think it's that's very
very very difficult analysis to make but
I think what we've seen in this country
is a rise in protests and the way people
are protesting that is interfering with
the rights of people to go around their
daily life you know it's stopping
ambulances stopping people get to school
stopping people going on motorways and
getting to work and I think we need to
redress that and that's what we've done
in Parliament to bring in new laws to
ensure that the balance is redressed and
we get that balance right I want to talk
about that in a minute um but that's not
what we saw was it at the correlation
protest and that's quite important to
say the Met police said that they
understand the concern but they police
proportionately and in the context of
the event I just wonder that phrase in
the context of the event does that mean
there are different thresholds for
policing a protests around coronation
well we should say I know the police
said that they understand the public
concerns but there were a large number
of protests that took place yesterday
with the police knowledge that we're
able to go ahead I think it is really
important that they take into account
the context of of the event because this
was an event that would have raised
questions about National Security this
was an event on the world stage and I
think it is really important for the
police to put that their policing into
that context and you mentioned the extra
powers that you've given to the police
to police protests including pounds to
stop and search without suspicion
including saying that a policeman may
stop any person or vehicle that they see
think fit to whether or not they have
any grounds for suspecting the person's
carrying a prohibited object
trust the police to use these new pounds
fairly uh well if they don't use them
fairly then there are consequences so
yes I mean I think policing is very
difficult the police are operationally
independent they have difficult
challenges but do you trust them to use
these new powers yes I do trust them to
use those new powers I've had a number
of meetings with the police over the
course of the last few weeks obviously
uh in relation to the coronation to
check everything they felt was on track
and I have huge confidence in the police
I mean some of these protesters are
we're talking generally now about the
reason why we've brought in this
legislation I mean over the last year
the police have spent 14 million pounds
dealing with just stop oil protests I
think it's absolutely right that they
have the powers that they need in order
to ensure that people can go to go on
their day-to-day lives at the same time
as respecting people's rights to protest
I guess I'm asking a question
specifically about the police because
you know we've just seen a very
important review saying that their map
polices institutionally racist and
misogynistic more than 90 officers found
guilty of crimes themselves last year
from violence to sexual sentences public
confidence understandably at a real low
is this the time to be giving the police
more powers
uh well wait you asked me a question
about the operational ability of course
the police have had a difficult time and
the reviews that you have mentioned and
the unfortunate instance uh you know
have taken place and there have been
there have been reviews to ensure that
there's more police vetting which is
absolutely right
um obviously police should be respecting
um the the people that they deal with
Witnesses victims and women
um and I think those steps are now being
taken okay
I want to move on to the local elections
if I may um how would you describe your
performance
well first of all I would like to say
you know lots of counselors have lost
their seat from from a variety of
parties and they've worked really hard
in their local communities and of course
that is a real shame party in particular
though wouldn't you say well you're
right to say that we we have been in
government now for 13 years we've been
if we could look at the context for the
whole uh local election uh we've been in
power for a long time we've just had a
pandemic which has disrupted many
people's lives and has had consequences
for the economy as has the war in
Ukraine which is going on and we
understand the concerns of the British
people you know what we're focusing on
now is ensuring that we cut inflation
and we're having some success there you
know cut the debt uh grow the economy
and make sure that we protect the NHS
you know it's it's sometimes I feel like
the last couple of days listening to you
conservative politicians reflecting the
results
do you really get what's happened
totally totally it's really important
that we listen to people I know people
are frustrated
this isn't just oh look we've had 13
years of course we're going to dip a few
seats like hundreds and hundreds of
seats were lost by the conservatives
yeah labor now yes the largest party in
local government I mean you're losing
all over the place Medway Windsor
basically anyone who's up against you
greens even we're taking seats do you
get what we've had totally and we've had
a really on top of the things I
mentioned I totally recognized we've had
a really difficult few years I do think
that the Prime Minister who's now been
in office for six months is getting the
country back on track and is delivering
and I think we're starting to gain the
trust of the British public well we have
we have we have absolutely what's your
evidence for that that you're gaining
the trust of the British public what has
rejected you at the local elections um
well in my own seat obviously I've spent
a large number of hours knocking on
doors and speaking to people across my
constituency and I've seen a little bit
of a shift in the last even from the
beginning of the campaign to the end of
the campaign you know they were angry
and frustrated and the cost of living is
difficult but I think what they are
seeing and I hope what they're seeing is
that the prime minister is starting to
deliver in a quiet way for the British
people and just just to come on to the
other parties you know labor didn't have
it did well
um I I accept that but if he wants to
get a majority of the next election it
needed to do better so you know the
statistics show that if to win uh at a
general election in the previous local
election you need to be 13 14 points up
and they're around eight points up so
they do need to do better look we can
have a debate over whether or not these
results show that labor doesn't calls
for a minority or majority government
but what the results show is that you
guys are on course being turfed out
so we've got somewhere to go we need to
continue working hard I totally
understand that we need to do better and
I think we are going to deliver that I'm
going to say
um and and I totally recognize that uh
we could have done much better and the
results were not good but you know in my
own constituency we were facing
um we we held the council by uh onesie
previously and we still hold for Council
so you know there are areas in the
country where the results were okay so
how are you going to change them if
you're listening to what the voters are
saying I I read in the papers that you
apparently the cabinet minister who
topped the league table for doing the
most campaigning out and about so you're
the one talking to voters you're
listening to them if you're hearing
their message how does your government
need to change we need to deliver on
what matters to people and I think what
matters most to them is their day-to-day
spending and the cost of living and our
our key focus is getting inflation down
so no change then things
because that's what you just said before
right uh well we need to deliver people
need to see that we're a government that
says what it's going to do and then it
delivers it so that's what we've said
we're going to do and we've started on
that Journey but we need to deliver it
um and then I think once we have
delivered it and people have seen
progress then we earn their trust back
and we can start talking to them and
delivering on other things as well some
of your colleagues I think that the
change needs to be a bit more rapid
frankly
um I've spoken to some Kosovo concerto
MPS who say that Russia student act as a
problem John Redwood has been busy
tweeting this morning not Russia Cena's
biggest fan it must be said but look
this is just one of his tweets that we
can have a look at last Thursday many
conservative voters went on strike they
don't want to vote for higher taxes
anti-enterprise policies and a failure
to Take Back Control of our borders he
went on to say if taxes have to be this
high wire public service is not better
well I think well first first of all I
work with Rashid for a year in the
treasury and I think he's outstanding at
delivering his decent hard-working and I
think he is showing he's capable of
delivering and he scores well in the
polls so I think he's doing a good job
obviously there's still more we need to
do we are doing those things we are
doing those things well the best the
biggest tax cut we can make is a cut in
inflation that's that's not really what
John Reb was talking about though is
he's talking about the tax burner well
I'd like well the most important thing
is what do people feel like how do they
feel the economy is affecting them and a
cut in inflation is the biggest tax cut
they can get we are not actually a tax
cut is it you can't say you're
delivering what he wants because he's
asking for tax cards well you know what
what I think is important is that people
feel the effect in their pocket so you
know the first step of that is to cut
inflation we are taking back control of
our borders you know you will know we're
taking on legislation you'll know we've
done a deal with Albania you'll know
we're working king with a French you
know we are making sure that we stop the
boats and we take control of our
immigration and the ensure that people
come here come here legally and through
safe routes okay I just want to talk a
little bit with your media hat on if I'm
as well and I spoke to you kirst armor
last weekend who said that there are
still outstanding issues when it comes
to regulation of the media and press is
he right
uh well I think that I'm very proud of
our media um I think it's a we are a
democracy and it's really important that
we have uh Free Speech you'll know I'm
also in charge of the BBC and uh I think
the BBC is a huge asset uh to this
country uh we will be repealing section
um and uh to ensure that the media
continues to have that ability to hold
uh politicians and others to account I
mean there has been a lot of scrutiny
hasn't there of the BBC recently with
the resignation of Richard Sharp the
chairman is it time as kirst armor is
saying to take all political
interference out of that role
no
um and I think it's interesting he says
that because when labor is in power they
made political appointments yeah but he
wants to do a different thing doesn't he
he's not he's saying that look let's
just change the whole thing going
forward the BBC a charter sets out how
the BBC chairman is appointed and we
will be following the BBC Charter but
what's really important to state is that
in selecting the next chair of the BBC
we will be looking for the best
candidate and that will be our Focus who
is the going to be the best chair of the
BBC and if they happen to have political
allegiances or they've supported a party
in the past whether that is the
conservative party or the labor party or
indeed any other party I don't think
that should disqualify them if they are
the best candidate for the job that's
the problem isn't it I guess people are
questioning whether or not the best
candidate for the job has always been
the criteria no the the the the criteria
on which I will be appointing and I'm
sure the Prime Minister will be
appointing the next chair the BBC is the
best candidate for the job and I do not
so there might be a labor supporter I
strongly believe uh that we should not
disqualify people from public office who
put themselves forward who are capable
of doing a job because they happen to
have in the past support to the
political so you'll be looking at Labor
candidates and concerts I've been
looking for the best candidate for the
job okay Eurovision next weekend yes
what's your prediction bye
I don't make predictions uh I'm really
looking come on I won't hold you I'm
really looking forward to going
um
really and it's not just actually about
your revision and the song contest uh
the city of Liverpool has done a
phenomenal job of uh supporting and
promoting Ukrainian culture I've spoken
to the Ukrainian culture Minister a
number of times I'm really looking
forward to hosting him as well and I
think it's just going to be a huge
celebration recognizing the tragedy
that's going on in Ukraine at the moment
thank you very much thank you
well you saw the the difficult questions
about the election results for the
conservatives well the numbers make
slightly different reading shall we say
for the little Democrats because they
now control 16 councils and it's perhaps
where they want that matters most
because throughout the so-called blue
wall they picked up seats in traditional
conservative areas Windsor and
maidenhead Hertfordshire Stratford Pawn
Avon and those areas currently have
conservative MPS so the next challenge
is turning those into general election
votes we're joined by the deputy leader
of the liberal Democrats data key Focus
to have you on the show this morning and
I just want to start off with the
coronation it feels like such a big
story this weekend doesn't it what were
you doing yesterday ah I was watching it
on the television at home I thought the
the colors the the music everything it's
a fantastic um spectacle it was
fantastic to watch are you a bit of a
royalist or do you know what I think in
this country we've got lots of people
who are staunch royalists and some who
sort of staunch Republicans I put myself
sort of somewhere in the middle you know
as a politician it wouldn't surprise you
that the things that worry me day to day
are things like the cost of living I
want to talk to you a bit about the
police handling of some of the protests
as well well um Lucy Fraser the culture
secretary said about interview she
thought the police got the balance right
between allowing people to celebrate the
coronation without being disturbed and
allowing people to protest peacefully do
you think the police got the balance
right
um I've got concerns that they may not
have done and we still need to see some
more information coming out about what's
actually happened some of that
information is unfolding but on the face
of it I do have concerns the fact is
that in this country whether you're a
royalist or whether you are a republican
we should all be able to agree on uh
free speech and the right to protest
there is a distinction between peaceful
protests on the one hand and disruptive
and
um uh violent protest on the other what
concerns me is that the conservative
government have introduced very
far-ranging uh sweeping powers for the
police which affects all protests I
think what we may have seen uh yesterday
but we still don't know what we may have
seen uh is some of those new measures
are being used by the police I think
that puts the public in a difficult
position I think it puts the police in a
difficult position too and you're right
to say that some of these details need
to be investigated and followed through
but there have been talk of people
handing out rape alarms for example uh
being arrested someone with a megaphone
being arrested Gwen Smith the head of
Republic tweeted to say now that he's
out of the police station make no
mistake there is no longer the right to
Peaceful protests in the UK I mean that
is an incredibly troubling statement the
fact is that during the course of the
government's policing Bill and also
through the public order Bill liberal
Democrats made the point that actually
the police have all the powers that they
need they've always had powers to deal
with disruptive and violent protests I
think what worries me is that the
conservative governments have now
increased these sort of wide-ranging
powers to police or protests what they
haven't done is enshrined the sort of
legal responsibility and the duty on the
police to actually facilitate peaceful
process I was part of a cross-party
group in Parliament that actually looked
at this issue we took ever we took
evidence from people from the Met and
from protesters in the wake of the Sarah
everard vigil where the policing was
found in court to have been handled
really badly and as a result of that
inquiry that we LED we said there should
be a code of conduct around how protests
should be policed in this country we're
clearly a very long way from getting the
balance right I mean I guess look to put
the other side of this right we have
seen in recent years very disruptive
protests which have been made it
difficult for ambulancers to get through
to people to you know make it to
important Hospital appointments because
of a disruptive nature of those protests
that is what the government would say
they're trying to stop
um I absolutely condemn those kinds of
protests I mean if I had been that woman
which I saw on the television who was in
her car desperately trying to get to see
her mother in a hospital I you know I
would have been probably even more Angry
than that that particular woman was so
of course um whether you've got violent
and disruptive protests there have to be
the powers to deal with that but those
Powers have already existed I think what
we've seen is the government has
introduced these new powers that apply
to all types of protests and therefore
there is a real kind of chilling effect
on the right to peaceful protest I think
it's time that the government would lot
more clear about ensuring that the
police have a responsibility to uphold
and facilitate peaceful protests in this
country and we need a proper code of
conduct so the public knows where they
stand and the police know where they
stand so we can retain trust in the
police as well okay um I want to talk
about the local elections you had a
pretty bumper set of results uh shall we
say improving even on your 2019
performance which was a pretty high bar
I can see you smiling
um how would you describe them well it
was a record-breaking set of results for
us and we really did exceed all of our
own expectations
um I think what we can say is that we've
obviously taken control of a number of
councils and this weekend there'll be a
number of the conservative big beasts
you know Michael Gove Jeremy Hunt former
prime minister Theresa may even the deem
zahawi who will have woken up to having
a liberal democrat-run Council and
they'll be looking over their shoulder
knowing that we're now coming for their
parliamentary seats at the next general
election so are you the opposition then
to the conservatives in some of these
the blue wall absolutely there are many
places around the country around 80
seats where the liberal Democrats are
key challenges to the conservatives we
call it the blue wall area and we hope
very much at the next general election
to win as many of those seats as
possible I mean I guess some would say
let's not get too carried away the lib
Dems always do well in local elections
and historically you really haven't
managed to break through that much in
terms of parliamentary seats well you
know I'm
friends on the MP for Saint Albans and
if you look at what happened there in
2019 we took control of the council in
the summer months and then just a few
months later we won the Parliamentary
seat as well so there is you know I am
living proof of the fact that you can
win at the local level and then using
that as a springboard to actually win a
parliamentary seat as well and that's
certainly a model we'll be using in many
other places across the country so the
results themselves pointed according to
Sky News analysis to labor being the
largest party but short of a majority I
just want
from the coronation if I may I think we
could have a look at that
kissed armor there Anna Davie sitting
next to each other they're having a bit
of a chat at one point I do think
they're sort of could be a deal between
these two guys
I mean let's be honest
If I Was An Athlete and I said to you
I've got 12 months until I have to run
the race of my life
and a journalist said to the athletes
well what are you going to do the day
after the athlete would rightly say look
I'm just focused on that particular race
and we're in exactly the same position
as politicians as a liberal Democrat
Deputy leader I'm working with Ed to put
our party on a general election footing
we have got a laser-like focus on trying
to get as many liberal Democrat MPS
elected as possible when the general
election comes and we're just not even
contemplating or thinking about what
might happen after that at the same time
though I'm not sure I buy it because
you've previously ruled out a coalition
with the conservatives why won't you
ruin one out with labor well because the
conservatives are in power at the moment
it's it abundantly clear for us to see
that's not
um you know relevant is it well
absolutely you're talking about
potentials you'll say you're not talking
about this because it's a a possibility
rather than a reality why won't you rule
out labor if you're prepared to rule out
with conservatives day in day out we can
see the damage that the conservative
party are doing to our country you know
whether it's the NHS that they're just
driving into the ground whether it's
um you know the blowing a hole in the
nation's finances whether whether it's
you know continuing to allow water
companies to pump sewage into rivers and
onto our beaches we can see the damage
the conservative party are doing and the
reason that we've had those three
stunning by-election wins is because
lifelong conservative voters are voting
for the liberal Democrats in part
because they want to get rid of this
conservative government it is our
responsibility our moral responsibility
We Believe to outh the conservative and
ask as many conservative MPS as possible
but as regards to labor I mean they will
stand on their own on their own platform
and we will stand on our own platform we
won't be defined by another party we
have our own set of our open liberal
values we're internationalists we're
environmentalists we know we're
pro-business we're pro-public sector we
believe in devolving power to local
communities this is the platform that we
will stand on and we'll use every
opportunity between now and the general
election to make the case for voting
liberal Democrats so it sounds to me
like you would consider doing a deal
with labor as I say
um we have ruled out working with the
conservatives because of the damage
they're doing to the country but you
haven't ruled out working with labor
everything we do between now the general
election will be about focusing on
getting liberal Democrat MPS elected
yeah but that's not the question I asked
that was it well that's what we're
planning to do everything between now
and the general election is getting
liberal Democrat MPS elected would it
change the voting system be a red line
in any live damn deal well it will
suddenly be in our Manifesto I mean it's
been in our Manifesto almost every
single election I think will be almost
every election uh since the formation of
the party and at the moment we have an
incredibly unfair voting system where
you know the political parties
themselves focus on a very small number
of votes in particular seats and a
number of people feel very
disenfranchised so it's very important
to us as liberal Democrats that we um
that we do have a fairer voting system
it'll be in our Manifesto and certainly
you know our own discussion well it'll
be in our Manifesto and it's a priority
for the party it always has been it
always will be how about rejoining the
EU is that over them for the lib Dems
well we would love to have the UK back
at the heart of Europe we've set out a
four stage plan as to how we want to do
that there are two very easy steps that
the government of the day could take
today improving our current trade deal
and rejoining you know other programs
whether it's education or science how
about the single Market well that's part
of our four stage plan eventually we
would like to end up in the single
Market we shouldn't underestimate though
how much damage to the trust and
relationship we have to EU with the EU
the conservatives have actually done the
damage has been really really
devastating I think as and when we have
managed to get a deal through recently
haven't they and actually EU leaders
tell me that you know they find where
she's doing someone that they can do it
with but they can deal with yes but in
terms of you know rebuilding their
relationship with the UK as a whole I
think there's been there's been a huge
amount of damage done by this
conservative government liberal
Democrats want us to have the UK at the
heart of Europe and we've got that four
stage plan which will take us into the
single Market okay now last weekend I
asked armor at Arsenal we're going to
win the Premier League he said no so
Auburn City a few leagues down from
Saint Albans from Arsenal um they're in
the playoffs today are you confident
they might get promotion oh fingers
crossed I'm pretty sure they will come
on the Saints
uh lovely thank you very much uh indeed
Daisy Cooper there for the liberal
Democrats so busy uh program uh today
lots on the coronation it does feel like
there's been a bit of a difference in
views on the policing of those protests
in particular with Lucy Fraser for the
conservatives saying that the police got
the balance right but Daisy Cooper there
saying that actually she does have some
concerns about how those protests are
working quite carefully not ruling out a
coalition with the labor party as well I
thought now as usual the take will
follow this program just after 9 30 a
chance to analyze today's interviews
talk for any news lines with our Deputy
political editor Sam coats now normally
at this point you have a nice view of
Sam's living room today he's here in
person he's alive he exists he's a real
person here in 3D um you know it's a big
weekend when you come into the studio
and what's your sort of take on all the
local election news around
I mean all the parties are kind of
reeling from what was quite a dramatic
result I was struck that Lucy Fraser
blamed covid and the Ukraine war for the
very poor showing by the conservatives
worse than the worst expectations uh set
by uh the academics but the one thing
that stood out more than anything else
was the way that labor and West
streeting in this studio has responded
to it now I thought West treating was on
quite fighty form attacking questions
about whether or not they were going to
get an overall majority or not they sort
of say that they're illegitimate I think
quite important tactic that's going on
that leads them to do that because they
want to scare the media off they want to
scare the public off this conversation
about what would happen if they didn't
quite get enough seats to have more than
half the MPS in the House of Commons
because then they'd have to have
discussions do deals with other
political parties and they don't want to
get into that territory they fear the
conservatives will exploit that so in
order to do that they just say that's
not an issue it is the questions are
legitimate it's unclear what they would
do and it's no good just attacking the
media for asking the question yeah I
thought he was um yeah let's say fighty
form uh certainly and it was quite
interesting as well listen to Daisy
Cooper very carefully not rule anything
out as well and talking about changes to
the voting system as a priority for her
party as well these are the kind of
things we're going to start talking
about more absolutely the liberal
Democrats are being quite open about it
they could never put a conservative
prime minister in number 10 in in a hung
Parliament there is no way on the basis
that their campaign their message has
stopping just short of saying it but on
the basis of what they've said there's
absolutely no way that's big problem for
the conservatives almost nobody would
put Rishi sunak back in number 10 in the
event that there's a hung Parliament the
political scene is changing I will have
more from Sam later on uh in the hour
but in the meantime we've just been
talking about the challenge facing the
conservatives this morning you know
they've suffered a serious defeat in the
local elections and of course as Sam
will say with the general election due
next year they remain consistently
behind in the polls the question now is
how or can they even turn things around
we're joined by the concept of MP former
Minister Jackie Doyle price uh thank you
for being on the program this morning
I'm over a thousand seats lost Medway
Windsor East Staffordshire pretty much
everywhere people are taking six of the
conservatives
they are but but frankly I still would
have expected uh the labor party has
been much much better than they did on
Thursday I mean if we look locally here
a lot of the games were made by
Independents rather than by the labor
party and if labor an absolute shoe-in
to getting a majority at the next
election they should have been romping
home but what we've actually seen is an
anti-conservative vote uh split between
labor and liberal Democrats the greens
and independents which tells you that
really the jury's still out on us and
what happens at the next general
elections is entirely due to what the
conservative party does between now and
then
I just want to pick up because
there's lots of questions and debate
about the size of Labor's win is it
enough to get to a majority but it feels
to me like you know the real message was
the rejection of the conservative party
like you say you lost to almost
everybody Independence the labor party
the greens the lib Dems
all that points towards to the
conservatives losing power do you think
your party's really woken up to that
I think what points to Sophie is the
shocking 18 months the conservative
party has had and frankly you know we've
reduced we've reduced politics to a soap
opera over the last 30 months
immediately prior to that we were master
of always surveyed so I don't blame the
election for being crossed with us I
don't blame them because kicking but the
conservative party has a brand which is
grown up and competent and that's what
we need to recover I still think we're
very much in play at the next general
election but it depends very much on
what we do between now and then what do
you think you should do then
well we now have a new leadership we
have a we have a narrative which I think
we need to look very carefully at that
narrative and go back to First
principles about what we believe in as
conservatives which is you know people
be able to keep more of what they earn
and the state only spending when it can
do so effectively I think we need to
become more disciplined in our frankly
I'm horrified to see that people want to
wait to put us through another
leadership election as if four in a year
would be more not too many
um we need to just United start being
grown up and start delivering and we
need to stop bickering amongst ourselves
we need to stop focusing on big
personalities and we need to get on with
the business of government it's that
simple that's what the public expects
the public don't want to see you know
battles in the news they just want to be
able to be confident that the
government's doing its best to deliver
and that's not what they're seeing for
the last 18 months you said they're
about people being able to keep more of
what they earn do you think that there
should be a reduction in taxes then
well I think we need to have a sensible
discussion about public spending
there is no doubt obviously when what we
had to do to combat covid that was going
to lead to spending a lot of money that
money needs to be paid back we cannot
live beyond our means and I'm afraid
what the conservative party has done
it's it's chased after labor party on
its own territory it's allowing itself
to be defined by how much it spends on
things rather than what it delivers and
you know if you think think back to the
narrative at the last general election
when we were talking about you know 50
000 more nurses and more hospitals that
isn't what it's about it's about being
able to deliver the best services with
the money at hand and we are now in a
position where our tax rates are
uncompetitive they are limiting growth
uh the way we've handled our Economic
Policy isn't incentivizing investments
in productivity and that's what we need
to be that's the conservative party
about nothing if it's not about economic
competence and I'm afraid we are we have
let ourselves due to lots of
circumstances be fighting on an on a
debate about public spending we're never
going to win that we can't out labor
labor about how much they spend because
we recognize that tax has to be
competitive and you know again I come
back to my original Point start
governing like conservatives and we will
be re-elected as conservatives I asked
Lucy Fraser about taxes and she said
that bringing inflation down would be a
tax cut do you think that's enough
um what I would say is that I do trust
Jeremy Hunt to have a sensible Economic
Policy which isn't reckless I think we
should do all we can to reduce taxes uh
I I'm doing all you can to reduce taxes
now
I think we need to have a sensibly
advice about spending and sensible
debates about what we're doing to you
know release economic activity
um I would I would like to hope that if
we carry on as we are going we can you
know go back to where we were and start
reducing taxes and I trust Jeremy Hunt
to be able to do that because he is a
good conservative
but just finally
um you know I've been interviewing
conservative front benches and MPS since
the results started coming in on Friday
morning
and it does strike me that the line
seems to be we need to just deliver on
what we're already doing we just need to
stick to the plan and keep delivering on
what we're already doing do you think
there is a risk that that doesn't really
grasp the message that voters have just
sent
well as I say I think the the message
versus descent is about is about history
of the last 18 months uh I think it's
also about the fact that you know for
people who are used to voting
conservative they have an idea about
what the conservative party is and we're
not currently delivering on that I mean
I got that on the door all the time
people do think that the government's
spending uh far too much uh money so
I mean in the sense that you know we
have a narrative at the moment
um
I I think that what the election results
show on Thursdays that's not quite
cutting through and perhaps there is a
case for rebooting that message but but
that's what happens after the elections
you you take stock about the message
that you've been given and and you act
accordingly but I think it's more about
reassuring people that you know we are
not going to carry on borrowing and
spending in the way that we have and we
are going to refocus and be a good
conservative government that delivers
economic competence that doesn't over
promise and that allows people to keep
more of what they earn
okay thank you very much indeed really
interesting to talk to you on the
program today Jackie board door price
then thank you very much
well we can reflect a bit now on what
we've been talking about this morning
and also look ahead to politics I was
going to say the political week to come
but really it's much warm that is the
political year to come we're gonna be
looking ahead to the next election and
the real challenges that have become
pretty evident uh since those local
elections on Thursday there's also Lots
on the agenda around the coronation too
and I'm joined by two women who
certainly know their way around
Westminster the former political advisor
to labor Aisha hazarika and samashar who
is a special advisor to the conservative
Home Secretary sacho Javid thanks for
being on the show both of you I mean you
were just in the introduction they're
saying that you're a former advisor to
Sasha Javit I mean his constituency area
was lost by the conservatives I mean how
much of a difficult night was it you
think I think there's no escaping the
fact that a loss of over a thousand
seats is a pretty significant hit for
the conservative party and you know
nobody's making any bones about that it
is this question of how you then sort of
present this result to people and The
Challenge from a tactical perspective is
what happened where and as we've seen
already people like Boris Johnson are
already trying to start you know little
skirmishes for the prime minister to
have to deal with and how do you create
confidence within your own party after
results like this and keep the faith and
keep them motivated to get to a general
election and so you know your previous
interview Jackie Doyle price she's
talking about sort of tax cuts and being
a true conservative
uh there is no conservative that would
disagree with that but principle is some
point going to hit reality and that is
what Rishi sunak and the conservatives
at a national level are going to have to
start considering I guess what people
like Jackie door price won't be feeling
though is you can't just keep doing the
same thing this is where she's your next
first test at The Ballot Box right yeah
since becoming prime minister and the
message is quite clear people don't like
what he's offering yeah and I think this
is something that they're really going
to have to start considering because
obviously he came in as prime minister
as the default Choice after I mean let's
not deny it lives trust messed up so
badly
um and so far he's been sort of ticking
along trying to sort of bring things
back into good order but the thing that
he doesn't have and which he's been
criticized for significantly is that
vision is that sense of purpose is that
sense of hope and that diagnosis of what
is the problem and how are how is he the
right guy to fix it and I think there is
that idea that being too technocratic is
not really appealing to people and if
you're the government you do you have a
little bit of power to set the agenda I
mean you are the government at the end
of the day and there is that little bit
of caution about thinking about that
political messaging that I think is
going to have to change in this next
year if he's got a chance of making
these numbers move around a little bit
to give himself not but potentially not
a victory but at least some damage
control take a few more risks basically
um how about Labor West streeting was a
bit
um touchy at some point saying look even
if kirstan was on his way to meet the
queen then you guys would still be
questioning yeah I saw that I liked your
answer which is like listen to that if
that moment happens I promise you are
look I do think that I think where
there's a definitely a little bit of
Truth to what where streaton says there
is a bit of a I think a slightly retro
narrative and a bit of a lazy narrative
just saying Libra's had like a really
really terrible night and I think if you
just take a step back if you look at
where kyostarma was just three years ago
when he took over the labor party the
party was completely in the toilet and
people like me who a really close label
watches we didn't think labor would be
competitive for seriously about 10 years
so it's quite an achievement to be where
we are and of course there's a big
question about whether labor is on
course for a majority yet and that's a
definitely a legitimate thing to to talk
about but I think we just need to to
look at a couple of facts which are
really really important labor did really
well at these elections for the first
time in a long time there were more
labor councilors than not they were
winning really interesting seats from
Swindon which is a real Bellwether seat
to to places like um Medway and however
you cut it it does look like the
conservatives are now in a very
difficult death spiral as you see
first-time Rishi sunat tested at The
Ballot Box went really badly the fact
that their expectation management of a
thousand losing a thousand seats became
a self-fulfilling prophecy is really bad
news and the big takeaway I think for a
lot of people is unless something
miraculously happens with Rishi sunak
and the country there is is going to be
a labor prime minister there's a high
possibility that for the first time in
14 years come the next general election
there will be a labor prime minister in
dining Street and that is a big moment
in terms of The Narrative of British
politics because we have not been at
this position for a long time even when
I worked for Ed Miller Band you know we
were never you know talking really about
the possibility of a majority labor
government yes right towards the end of
the election we thought there could be
maybe a hung Parliament or labor being
the largest party and of course these
election results didn't take into effect
uh into Scotland into account and things
have changed massively in Scotland so I
would blimp though I just want to pick
you up on that because I think I'm right
in saying that labor haven't got a
majority since the 1950s without winning
at least 40 seats in Scotland you've got
one at the minute I mean even if you do
well at Scotland it's a bit of a tall
order to be relying on Scotland right I
think the the mood has changed in
Scotland a lot and I think even if labor
was only hoping to maybe pick up between
six and ten seats if that now goes up
let's see post 20 that's quite a Tipping
Point in terms of helping you know get
to that sort of majority but look having
said all of that labor should absolutely
not be punching the ear and measuring up
the curtains because political history
tells us that it's very very difficult
for labor to cross the line you know
we've people like me who have been
around the labor party for a long time
know that and I think the party the
country is falling out of love with the
conservative party the question for Kia
stimer's strategists are they in love
with Kia stami yet and I think where
there is a legitimate question for the
labor party is right you have to sort of
flesh out a bit more of a a positive
Vision you don't want to just scrape a
win because you're not the conservatives
you do want a positive compelling
mandate from the British public arguably
not just for one term but for two terms
and you want to start making that
positive case now and I want to talk to
you both a bit about the coronation did
you watch it yes Buckingham
this over I loved it
it was quite an amazing day wasn't it
and was there any sort of standout
moments for either of you though I'm
afraid for me the standout moment was a
new Queen has been crowned and her name
is Penny Warden any more than stole the
show Penny Morden I think actually I
have to say like no matter what side of
the political guy you're on
penny more than there carrying the sword
I mean look at the guns on that I know
two tickets to the gun show people are
calling a penny sword and
before
it could have been Chris Grayling not
quite the same impact or Jacob Reese
Mark I don't think Jacob we smog would
have had the arms strength to to carry
that so I mean it was really interesting
because I was covering it for American
Network and they were going absolutely
nuts about who penny more than it was
they were like who who is this person
but you know she I think she she had a
stand-up moment but it was a very it was
sort of what Brits do do best I mean it
was Bejeweled it was opulent the music
was incredible it was a bit mad at times
it was a bit Bonkers but there was that
great thing of fusing all that ancient
tradition and ritual with some quite
nice modern touches as well look we
haven't had one for 70 years and I think
that it's one of those moments that
actually where people if they do watch
it go oh that's what the monarchy is
about because in between all of that you
get like weddings and things and
people's life moments but you don't
actually get okay what what is this and
you know steeped in history in that in
the Christian tradition you know talking
about service and all of that I think it
makes a lot more sense but you know we
don't have coronations very often so
we've got to keep going back over it so
we're probably not going to have a
really big Royal Jamboree event like
this for quite a long time now there
will be you know hopefully fingers
crossed like a period of
um stability but I think it is important
to to note that obviously everybody
isn't mad keen on the on the monarchy
and I think these arrests yeah let's
have cast a bit of a stain all over
things let's talk about that shall we
um I was quite struck by Lucy Fraser
saying she thought the police had got
the balance right uh at the minute
between allowing people to enjoy the
coronation and not be disturbed but also
making sure people could protest and
there have been some difficult headlines
what's your take on this summer so look
everybody we are living a free country
monarchy or not and everybody has the
right to protest but we have rules that
govern protests in order to make it safe
for everyone I can't sort of predict
what the policeman on the ground were
thinking about but we have to take into
account that they are on the ground
they're understanding the situation they
have protocols and they have policies
around this now if that needs to be
challenged in some way there will have
to be a proper investigation but on the
face of it you know there are strict
rules around this the police are very
mindful of what they need to do
especially in a situation like this with
huge crowds that they have to keep
secure and safe and so I haven't seen
anything that suggests to me that it was
improper what do you think well I do
take the point that the police have got
you know a really really tough job to do
particularly on an event of this sort of
scale with this kind of crowd control
but I just want to see the information
that comes forward about whether they
did go in quite in quite a heavy-handed
way and I think what will be interesting
as well is whether they felt the sort of
overbearing political pressure because
we know this week there's been a lot of
focus on really cracking down on
protests along with a lot of criticism
of the police and the Metropolitan
Police so I just hope that they they
didn't act in a way which was completely
disproportionate because look we've
talked about what it means to be British
through through the monarchy and all the
pageantry and everything but but
protests and having like a diverse set
of views and freedom of speech is also
really important to to the DNA of this
country so we don't want to have a
situation where any sort of descent we
see a kind of russia-style Chinese style
Crackdown on everybody there's got to be
the right balance I think we'll have to
really wait for the facts to come out to
see if that that was the case in this
statement that the Met police put out
they said that they need to take into
consideration the context of the event
so do you think there's like a lower
threshold or if it's if there is is that
rights for this kind of policing look
there's two things that you have to be
really mindful of in these situations
and I you know when I was in government
we looked at big government events and
you know how you police crowds and
things like that the threat levels that
are going to be
um that are that are going to be present
you know the police are cautious and
understanding various different threats
so there's threats in terms of the crowd
control there's threats in terms of
personal security for the people who are
around they have seen these things
happen before with loud noises you know
designed to speak horses and things like
that on parade and also you know
potential of attacks within the crowds
so they are looking at a thousand
different things at any given point so I
I I often think that we we over
um we are over critical sometimes of a
very very hard job any coronation plans
later today or Street party obviously
Street party yeah and I'm sadly working
I'm presenting
but then I'm gonna have a bit of a rest
also because of what I was watching I
didn't you know there was so much going
on it was quite hard to see I think I'm
gonna go and re-watch some of it also
Simon and I were having a great little
fan that is but we have a great little
chat by the outfits I might go back and
have a little spending yeah we don't
think it was the best dressed no we're
supposed to say that on Earth people
sort of let the side down a bit apart
from Penny Ward yes I have to say that
dress was Flawless it really was um
thank you both very much indeed I'll let
you go to the work in the streets
that's it for this week's at safer Ridge
on Sunday in a moment though we only
running through today's interviews and
those local election results too with
our Deputy political editor Sam coats
thanks for joining us this Sunday
morning
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello welcome back this is safe Ridge on
Sunday the take a chance to look back at
our interviews this morning on the
program and try and work out what we
learned and in particular of course the
views on last week's local election
results now it was one of these programs
where you think um do we just need to
ditch the whole thing do we need to do
it from the coronation itself or should
we be doing it from Westminster and in
the end we went for the third option
loads of Coronation news on the show of
course in particular as well the
policing of some of those protests too
so a big focus in our interviews but of
course those local election results did
really feel like a moment in British
politics and although there is a
question about the size of the win is it
going to be a majority is it going to be
a minority if these results replicated
in a general election it would be care
starmer in number 10 a labor government
for the first time in a very long time
well with that in mind I can bring in
Sam Coates uh Deputy political editor uh
lovely to have you here in person Sam
it's a pleasure we know it's a big
weekend when that happens
and yeah the local election results
um we were there weren't we on Friday
and it really did feel as if it's quite
a moment in British politics that's
right I mean one of the weird things
that the coronation has done is sort of
stop the discussion about local
elections now maybe it's a minority of
people who who focus on that but it is
the whole of the Westminster Village the
whole of the British political system
does stop and take stock after something
as momentous as that but instead we had
you know man on chair gets hat uh is a
way of slightly you know full stopping
that conversation so we're going to try
and revive that this morning because it
was such a big moment
um as you say you can have that
discussion about quite how well labor
did and what side of the kind of
majority line that these results would
imply but there is not going to be a
conservative in number 10 after the
general election if there's anything
like these kinds of results and that's a
big deal right because yeah you could
say we knew that already look at the
polls but this is the first time we see
soon act has been tested at the ballot
paper and there has been a bit of talk
in Westminster hasn't known about is the
lead softlying is where she's doing it
managing to cut through and I have to
say this was a bit of a wake-up call it
was a bit and you know that there has
been a bit of a narrative in the last
couple of months based on polls based on
kind of appearances that Rishi sunak had
up the conservative's game that he had
uh slimmed down and honed a message that
he'd had a couple of wins when it comes
to the Windsor framework and that things
were going better and British politics
was
um more competitive again and so what's
important about Thursday is that it
shows that conservative expectations
were too high they were wrong they were
over optimistic they thought they were
too pleased with themselves they thought
they were going to do better and they
didn't and that is a shock you know I've
got conservative MPS going I'm depressed
at the result because I know I'm out of
a sea if it's anything like that which
is why the reaction of the conservatives
and the labor party is really important
but the big question the big kind of
personal group to focus on is rishis are
not in the government do they take this
as Jackie Joel price said to you labor
MP said to you as a wake-up call to stop
bickering and simplify their message or
as we sort of heard on Friday morning
when I met Rishi when you interviewed
Shadow cabinet members and then this
money from Lucy Fraser it's a bit more
head down carry on as we were yeah I
thought I thought that was the governor
interview as well which we'll hear from
uh in a moment but let's just I just
want to play we're shooting first
because we decided to start with our
labor guest which is unusual for us on
the program but perhaps some reflection
of those results and I asked him whether
a coalition with the libdens could be
the direction they're heading in just
listen to what we have to say
I just don't think that is the scenario
that we're going to be in after the next
general election if it is which is very
possible looking at these results
I honestly think Kia starmer could
literally be on the way to the Palace in
the car having just been summoned to be
prime minister of a majority party and
the conservative party in some parts of
the media's talking points would still
be always a difficult night for
conservatives but labor could have done
better come on I I'll give you my word
that if that is
I will not be asking these questions
however in these scenarios where the
results Point towards a hung Parliament
it is a legitimate question to answer
yeah I know I think we're this is a this
is a process not an event we're not at
the Final Destination yet take whole
where I say through gritted teeth the
liberal Democrats did rather well I
heard the lib Dem leader of whole
Council the other night saying well look
locally people have voted libden but the
general election people in the city vote
labor
you asked the wrong question of where's
treating how could you
I know I got in trouble there didn't I
uh on my street you wasn't happy with
that one but it is a legitimate question
right of course it is and and it's not
it's not surprised that we're treating
sort of wants to scare us all off
funnily enough it doesn't work
um from from having this discussion and
and there's a bit of historical context
recent history uh historical context to
that which is in the 2015 general
election campaign the conservatives who
you know were also at points in that
Parliament facing a resurgent labor
party stumbled across an incredibly
effective tactic in the wake of that
Scottish referendum that where Scotland
uh voted narrowly to remain part of the
United Kingdom they realized that the
election results pointed to the
possibility of a hung Parliament and so
what they did was they said well look if
there's a hung Parliament labor of the
largest party then you're going to have
Alex salmon the uh SNP leader and
Nicholas sturgeon pulling the strings of
Ed miliband making demands in order to
get through budgets legislation and even
possibly to determine who is in number
10 and that was incredibly effective it
really worked well and it's a tactic
that the toys have been sort of keeping
their eye on ever since it was
interesting though because
we were there when the um House of
Commons projection came in and I just
remember you the first thing you did
when you looked at the numbers and you
said well that would be a coalition with
a lived end not the SMP and you were
saying that that was significant and do
you think it's I guess
less of an issue for labor to be linked
with the lived ends than it would be the
SNP so undoubtedly uh the projection is
good for labor even if they fall short
they might not have to turn to a
nationalist party who quite clearly
whose values they oppose they tell me
they tell viewers uh they really reject
uh nationalism separatism uh the SMP
drive to break up the United Kingdom and
so they could never talk to them in any
scenario because there's coalitions but
there's also minority agreements you
know you know legislation by legislation
discussions there's all sorts of ways of
managing a hung Parliament and it's much
easier if you've got somebody another
party that was campaigning to out the
Tories that already speaking is
Progressive yes it has some policy
differences uh but but by and large
they're probably slightly closer bed
fellows if if if not completely
overlapping but I think it something
else it's not just the question of who
the bed fellow is the question is
whether or not by rolling out this
tactic the conservatives can try and
make kistama look weak there's a sort of
thing in British politics that isn't in
German politics or uh uh or other
political systems which is that we
fetishize our leaders looking decisive
kind of the the guy at the top or the
woman at the top taking unilateral
decisions and everyone has to bend to
their will And discussing coalitions
agreements with other political forces
has generally seen oddly in public as a
bit of a sort of dirty concept because
maybe it implies weakness of the person
at the top it's completely normal in
lots of other places in all over Europe
and uh and in Brussels uh but in Britain
it's seen as weakness and and I think
that yes is the question of who the
Coalition or the minority partner is if
if necessary or whether it's a a a a a
point-by-point deal but also it's this
they're trying to the choice will be
trying to plant the idea that kissed
armor might have to do deals and that's
weak and that's the message that they're
trying to get in people's brains it's
worth hearing from the labor party about
their retort to that not only do they
rule out any discussions with the SMP at
all indeed Western ruled out any
discussions with anybody but they make
the point that Rishi sunak is in a
coalition himself with his own party
with all these different factions and
indeed these different factions have
steered the conservative government of
the last 13 years in directions that the
Prime Minister would rather not have
taken take the brexit referendum David
Cameron wouldn't of his own volition
have ever gone near that hugely
Divergent way to labor go well look at
them just because it's they've all got
conservative badges doesn't mean that
they're not that the Couture it's
excessive Tory leaders aren't bullied by
their own party
um that's not going to happen to us so
it's a big argument and it's a big
argument that we're going to be having
in the weeks and months to come yeah I
can certainly see that and one that I
think labor are going to get frustrated
about as you saw in that interview as
well that's certainly perhaps not going
to go away but look as moon sign was
saying extraordinary night for labor and
really the big story is it's so
difficult now to see that Landing zone
for the concept of party ahead of the
next election which leads to the
question what are they going to do and
I'm sure we're going to get all sorts of
voices coming out with all sorts of
ideas about the direction that it needs
to go in already we've had this morning
for example John Redwood keyless trust
backer saying that the conservatives
need to cut taxes and on the program
today I spoke to the conservative MP
Jackie dog price about the local
election results this is what she thinks
the conservatives need to do what the
election results show on Thursdays
that's not quite cutting through and
perhaps there is a case for rebooting
that message but but that's what happens
after the elections you take stock about
the message that you've been given and
and you act accordingly but I think it's
more about reassuring people that you
know we are not going to carry on
borrowing and spending in the way that
we have and we are going to
refocus and be a good conservative woman
that delivers economic competence that
doesn't have a promise and that allows
people to keep more of what they earn
I mean look she's trying to be not to
show that she's putting the boot in too
much but the thing that came out of that
for me is she's calling for low attacks
that's right yeah I'm also very human
very it was good you enjoy listening to
Jackie Doyle price stop bickering she
told the party a little bit earlier in
that interview
um but yes there was a call um for lower
taxes but I thought in many ways
um what you just heard encapsulates the
conservative
um problem because she said that first
of all we need to change the message
then she said uh we need to be a more
conservative government so we've got to
borrow less spend less and then she said
but we've got to spend more because we
need to deliver tax cuts which of course
involves spending money and the bottom
line Sophie is we're at that point in
the political cycle where bluntly you
can't do big reform because there isn't
time and you know you don't anything
that's big reform upsets people and you
don't have that much cash left you know
there's not much money left and what so
all they can do is throw cash at the
electorate and promise to throw cash at
the lecture in the form of tax cuts this
side and the other side of a general
election so yeah that's why Tory MP is
going to ask for yeah it's probably what
they're going to get in the Autumn
statement in all likelihood Jeremy Hunt
will announce uh the chancellor will
announce um a sort of targeted tax cuts
in the lead-up to the election as a sort
of sweetener
um but that's the the as Dominic
Cummings always said Downing streets
only leave her when they're in a hole is
to Splash the cash and to and to cut
taxes and there is there are they didn't
have any other levers that they can pull
it does feel like an incredible bind and
they either take a risk which they need
to they look at the polls but then do
they undo their reputation for economic
competence and then if you are making
reforms who are you going to try and
appeal to the red wall voters who are
leaking to labor or the blue War voters
so we're looking to the live Downs it
really does feel very difficult indeed
and now Sam obviously is very excited
about the local election results and
wants to talks about the politics but I
am going to force him to talk a little
bit about the coronation in particular
of course the protesting because the
police have been accused by Salma being
too quick to arrest protesters at
yesterday's coronation even though they
had warned that they'd have a low
tolerance over protests have a quick
listen now to Daisy Cooper and also Lucy
Fraser when I asked them about it
I've got concerns that they may not have
done and we still need to see some more
information coming out about what's
actually happened some of that
information is unfolding but on the face
of it I do have concerns the fact is
that in this country whether you're a
royalist or whether you are a republican
we should all be able to agree on free
speech and the right to protest there is
a distinction between peaceful protests
on the one hand and disruptive and
um uh violent protest on the other what
concerns me is that the conservative
government have introduced very
far-ranging sweeping powers for the
police which affects all protests I
think what we may have seen yesterday
but we still don't know what we may have
seen uh is some of those new measures
are being used by the police
the police are operationally independent
uh from government but what they had to
do was to police you know an
International Event uh on the world
stage and I think they took that into
account in their policing and what they
have to do is balance the right of
people's uh the right to protest which
is important in a democracy at the same
time as the right of all those other
people to enjoy what was a fabulous day
and and I I don't know the the instances
the particular instances but I think
overall they managed to get that balance
right
well it really felt there didn't it that
there was a bit of a dividing line there
between the liberal Democrats and the
conservatives when it comes to the
protesting and the policing of that
which I guess you'd expect right and
they're both
um parties who would have naturally
different positions on it but it does
feel like with these big occasions the
big Royal events there's so much
politics in the way that politicians
have to respond to it that's right
there's it's fashionable to say that the
monarchy is above politics and in some
sense is that true but but really it's
not and and watching bits of the
coverage last night what really strikes
you is that we spend our whole time
talking about politicians perhaps the
most temporary bit of you know the
British State they come and go but
Monarch's endure and it it is now King
Charles's government uh that we're
discussing it will be for him uh to
receive whoever is the prime minister
after the next election one prominent
politician Penny Warden played an
extraordinarily uh impressive role
carrying the sword as Lord privy seal uh
Jesus I won't do her leadership chances
is any harm exactly and in an amazing
outfit and um and I think that it's a
reminder that there's more to the
British State than what goes on in down
the street it did make me realize how
careful labor has to be on this because
Kirsten has done a lot to show that he
is a patriotic politician and we're
streeting as well are you a bit of a
royalist yes yes I am a royalist we're
streeting to the person you put out on
mornings like this there's no danger of
a kind of double-edged nuanced answer
from Wes not sure about the rest of the
Shadow cabinet
um yeah exactly how to put the camera
they were looking through the list
routine he can do he can do the
interviews this morning definitely see
that
um how about you Sam you bit of a
monarchist you out about celebrating the
coronation it's a bit weird day
yesterday it wasn't a bank holiday so
all the usual kids classes so miss the
coronation but then caught it all up at
nine o'clock the one hour Sky special
it's still on YouTube highly recommend
it I did I did watch it all with the
family
managed to
do a day which I feel is actually a
great idea because the weather yesterday
was quite sadly appalling when I'm going
camping in the rain so that's how you
celebrate coronation weekend properly I
think okay well that's what you need to
recover I think perhaps from those local
election results really busy at weekend
here in Westminster absolutely
incredible spectacle of the coronation
uh we'll be back to full coverage of
that on Sky News after this small pause
for a bit of political reflection on the
local elections uh important of course
because it really does feel like what
happened on Thursday could have
repercussions in the years to come that
is it from safe Ridge on Sunday the take
this morning the podcast will follow
around lunchtime so definitely worth
checking that out with all the best
interviews on the program and to come we
are going to be seeing you again next
week I think we need a bit of a breather
to be honest after this weekend so have
a wonderful bank holiday weekend and I
hope you enjoy the quiches or the
Victoria sponges at whatever dance
parties you are at lots of course to
come on tv as well we'll see you next
week
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]